Is it just me or is Internet culture?
The trolling,
the outrage and the endless hate
starting to eat itself?
This election obviously brought out the
worst in almost everybody from real
people to twitter,
eggs and atomy avatars.
People are constantly attacking others
online and saying things that they would
never dare say to someone's face in real
life.
The really scary part of this though
isn't the words you guys know.
I love free speech,
but there seems to be no bottom to this
whole of anger.
Just think about your facebook and
twitter feeds for a moment or they
enlightening,
interesting and bringing joy and
goodness to your life.
Or are they an endless cascade of rants
and Raves,
psychotic,
ramblings,
endless fighting and nonstop virtue
signaling.
I'm going to go out on a limb here and
guess that for most of you,
the answer is the latter.
Not the former,
and yes,
there are also a lot of baby pictures on
facebook which can be quite annoying.
What I think is most interesting about
our constant state of bickering isn't
the obvious fact that the Internet can
bring out the worst in all of us,
but that it seems to me that this
behavior and the reaction to it is now
bleeding out into the real world.
I'm slammed with emails every day in
which people explained to me how they're
suffering real world consequences for
what they post or even what they don't
post online.
People are getting fired over tweets,
losing friends over facebook posts and
God only knows what's happening on
snapchat,
but perhaps worse than all of this is
the chilling effect that this state of
outrage has on the rest of us.
This is why I've said it before and I'll
say it again.
The biggest threat to free speech is
that we are actively silencing
ourselves.
Not that the government is silencing us.
The threat to free speech isn't just
that protesters are violent at a milo
event.
It's the trickle down effect that that
has.
Now they're violent events for people.
I conservatives and Libertarians such as
Ben Shapiro and Charles Murray,
but of course it won't stop there
either.
Eventually they'll come for liberals to
while at the same time,
plenty of other people who just won't
want to deal with the threats.
Simply won't accept invitations to speak
in the first place.
The outrage machine will just dull us
all down to the point where we won't
share any original thought because we
just won't want to deal with the
repercussions.
This is exactly what's happening with
trump right now.
The mainstream media and the twitter
brigade go bananas every time anything
happens.
The result is that people won't be able
to gauge the proper outrage if he does
do something that truly warranted.
Yes,
he eats his steak with ketchup.
While it is well done.
That sounds horrible to me,
but you've got to deal with it.
Remember the boy who cried wolf?
Well,
now we've got the media who cried?
Trump,
you think I'm being alarmist here?
Well,
do we see more politically correct or
less politically correct than five years
ago?
What about 10 years ago?
Do you find yourself censoring yourself
more or less?
Now than you did even last year,
who is forcing you to censor yourself?
Is it the government?
I don't think so.
I bet you need only look in the mirror
and guess what?
This creep of stifling speech for fear
of being ostracized isn't going to
magically reverse itself.
We have to proactively fight it,
and we should have started this a long
time ago.
Take a minute and think about our
current television programming.
Could all in the family,
arguably the best Sitcom in television
history with a bigoted yet lovable
archie bunker,
possibly be on network television today.
The beauty of archie was that we all
know someone like him,
whether that person is white,
Brown,
or blue.
Only through seeing these people poking
fun at them and showing the short
sightedness of bigotry,
can we change our society to be more
thoughtful and decent for everybody?
Even when I watched Seinfeld with all of
its quirky,
racially based characters,
jokes about gays,
women,
and everyone else.
I think that the authoritarians will
come for the show about nothing,
which was really a show about everything
one day as well.
It won't be the government kicking
Jerian the crew off the air.
It'll be the next generation of social
justice warriors upset about the episode
where George wanted a black friend or
where Kramer wouldn't wear the aids
ribbon or the ones with characters like
ping the Chinese delivery guy or baboo
the Pakistani restaurant tour beyond the
outrage machine.
There is another nefarious layer here
which is a whole group of people who get
off on the outrage itself.
This is the group of people who react to
anything in everything,
so to get clicks and ultimately money
from our constant state of outrage.
So when Pewdie Pie makes a stupid joke
about Jews as they did a couple of weeks
ago,
the bigger reaction is from those who
want to capitalize on the moment rather
than those who are actually outraged by
the joke itself.
Then the mainstream media gets involved
with the Wall Street Journal writing
about the incident which subsequently
led maker studios to end their contract
with Pewdie Pie.
This destructive force will take anyone
down who has moved up to far.
The youtuber is attacking Pewdie Pie.
Wish they had his 55 million subscribers
and the Wall Street Journal's sees how
his influence,
believe it or not,
is now dwarfing their own as online
culture.
It gets woven into every facet of our
lives.
It's vital.
We all pick up and choose our spots when
to fight and when to be outraged.
If we're outraged at everything,
then we're outraged at nothing.
If we spend all day online trying to
find enemies as well,
then guess what?
Enemies will present themselves.
Making some intellectual point over an
opponent has value,
but we have to be careful that the value
isn't because of the retweets and
favorites it garners.
I'm sure I can be better at some of this
myself,
by the way,
especially on twitter.
Trolls are always going to troll,
but those of us who want to change
things for the better have to actually
be better ourselves.
Final thought.
I was a guest on the Alex Jones live
show last week at.
Some of you may have seen,
I'm not even fully familiar with Alex
beyond the little bites I see of him
screaming and generally going nuts.
That said,
the guy has a huge audience and is
clearly influential as mainstream media
crumbles and online media rises.
As I've said before,
this comes with both positives and
negatives,
but regardless,
the fact is the guy is talking to a huge
amount of people.
Immediately when I got the request to be
on the show,
I thought that I shouldn't do it because
of the ton of hate that I was about to
get.
Then I realized that if I didn't do the
show,
I would only be holding myself hostage
to the very same ideas which are
silencing so many other people right
now,
so I did the show with no preparation or
advanced questioning and Alex let me say
what I wanted to say.
Well,
I got the usual hate from the usual
haters just for appearing on the show.
I also know that I got some of the ideas
that I care about to be heard by his
large audience.
Now maybe some of them will come here
and learn more about the issues that you
and I care about.
If you're one of those new viewers,
welcome.
I don't yell as much,
but I think you'll dig it around here,
but for the record,
I do not believe that a secret group of
Lizard people are leading a shadow
government,
which is trying to undermine our
freedoms.
Obviously.
It's actually a group of frog men led by
pepe and they're actually a bunch of
freedom fighters.
Good luck to us all.
Joining me today is the author of
several books and the founder and
current president of the David Horowitz
Freedom Center.
David Horowitz.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
What are the chances that you ended up
being the president of a place called
the David Horowitz Freedom Center?
That is,
that is incredible.
I actually fought that name,
but my board said,
uh,
I had named it the center for the study
of popular culture as a,
as a leftist.
I thought it's a very hard to attack a
center for studying anything,
let alone just.
But conservatives see the word culture
and they think left.
So there was just confusing skype.
Amy and I said,
just kind of put your name on it.
So.
So here we are.
Alright.
So I don't know,
in the years that I've been doing this
show that I've read anyone's bio and
found it more interesting than your bio,
it will,
at least not someone that was born in
the United States.
I thought it was just,
there's so much richness there.
Your evolution politically,
it has a lot to do with some of the
things that you write about,
about going from the left to the right
and all that.
Um,
so I want to start with your history
first.
Your parents were communists hard.
Gary card carry everybody.
We,
it's like the communist that kids that
think it's cool today doing an old
school.
These are people who are part of a vast
international conspiracy orchestrated by
Moscow.
Um,
my parents,
my,
I don't think my mother ever got a
traffic ticket.
They were,
they were very middle class.
Not break the law,
but they did hide and East German
communist in the basement.
Who,
who the government wanted to deport
a.
How did he get to your basement?
I have no idea.
I was very young.
Did you know there was someone down
there?
I mean,
did you notice something was going to
either,
was his name the last name?
His brother was the mayor of East
Berlin.
Okay.
Um,
but um,
yeah,
they were very conspiratorial.
They never referred to themselves as
communists,
only as progressives.
Even then because it wasn't a dirty.
Well,
oh,
it was very dirty.
He was a dirty word.
It was very healthy period.
But because this anya American left very
subversive,
ready to work with the,
our enemies the up.
So you know,
a horrible totalitarian dictatorship
where effectively quarantined.
We lived in a kind of ghetto where you
couldn't say what you,
what you believed in that for a Democrat
with a small d for a liberal minded
person,
that doesn't seem right,
but it was actually healthy given the
cold war at the time.
So,
so,
so what did it mean to have a stigma on
people who hate this country?
We've lost that completely.
So,
so we'll get to that part because that
really sort of,
that gets to the evolution part of where
you're at.
We were stigmatized and a well,
what did they believe?
Like what did that actually mean?
If you said you were a communist,
and we're talking the 19 forties now,
nothing.
My mother was a registered Democrat.
I don't think anything different from
certainly not the Democratic Party of
today,
although then,
I mean,
when Roosevelt was president,
they were all happy Democrats.
When Truman declared that America would
defend free peoples fighting for their
freedom against the Soviet Union,
they all defected.
And that formed the Progressive Party
which was run by the Communist Party.
Yeah.
And then around 1956,
if I'm not mistaken,
all the information that comes out about
Stalin and then that sort of.
That was my away.
I was 17 at the time and that was my
kind of awakening that everything that
the William Buckley's.
So we hated to write that.
The right set,
the right set of Stalin had killed 7
million people.
He actually killed about 40 million.
Um,
and we said was this was all anti-soviet
lies.
The Soviet Union was a paradise of the
future.
Everybody equal everybody working,
everybody happy,
all lies.
But we've,
my community believed them.
And then Khrushchev came along with
this,
gave it a secret speech that the Israeli
Mossad smuggled out and it just,
it blew up my community that there were
divorces in our,
that we do have a over people over the
Khrushchev report.
People felt betrayed.
They had lived a lie and other people
felt,
you know,
you continue,
you go on and they defended it.
Yeah.
And that made marriage is untenable,
right?
You think p,
it's tough now for marriages when people
are going to.
I love trump.
I hate trump,
but,
but that's why.
That's earthshaking stuff.
Your whole narrative.
Yes.
So I came into the,
when I went to college,
I mean my mission self self developed a
was to rescue the left from Stalinism.
Um,
I still believed in this future,
wherever,
you know,
common government ownership of the means
of production and quality and
everything.
Um,
and so I,
I was a fervent new leftist.
I was one of the,
actually one of the creators of the new
left.
I was at Berkeley.
We published a magazine called root and
branch.
But by the end of that decade it was
clear.
The left was a totalitarian forest.
It couldn't fit in with supporting,
you know,
whatever was the men of malice,
malice.
Mao killed more people in style.
Um,
and uh,
so you saw that change from what you
thought,
something decent.
You saw that basically anything related
to authoritarianism would be sort of
pieced into my,
my most.
I had two serious deviations.
I had a nuclear family and everybody
else was living in communities or
whatever.
Um,
but the more serious one was that I read
books.
So I,
I mean,
I remember when billy airs was elected
vice president when the weather people
took over,
sds is a,
a college senior.
He boasted that he hadn't read a book in
a year.
I was horrified as a leftist by that
statement.
Um,
but what was his argument was what?
I'm not being programmed by these
people,
but then know to choose an irresponsible
twit.
I mean,
it's,
you know,
came from wealth very privileged.
I have,
I have nothing good to say about billy
airs,
but by saying I haven't read a book in
here,
who is he?
How is he trying to impress somebody?
But I know doing well because the books
are written by the ruling class or when
a got.
What did mark say?
The brulee ideas or the ideas of the
ruling class?
Completely false.
How would you explain our universities
today is full of crap.
I'd be the first thing yet.
Yeah.
Well we'll get to our universities.
Don't worry about that.
But wait a minute.
The first one you mentioned there was,
you came from a nuclear family and that.
Was that a problem?
I had a nuclear fence.
Yeah.
Oh,
you had your own nuclear.
I also came from a new,
quite the end of the decade.
I had four children.
Yeah.
So why was that a problem for them?
Because they want.
They didn't,
I wasn't expelled from the left.
I,
uh,
I was um.
Well what happened to me was that I,
I edited ramparts,
which was the leading,
it was the biggest magazine of the left
and a Hollywood producer,
producer.
Vz Writer,
um,
was a big funder and sponsor of the
Black Panther party.
And He introduced me to Huey Newton
because he wanted me to take eldridge.
Cleaver had been on our masthead,
uh,
and eldridge there was a war.
It was basically a Black Panther party
as a street gang.
And uh,
this was a contest for leadership.
Um,
so he,
uh,
he introduced me and I got to involve
raising money for the panthers I raised
per school.
Um,
I was very impressed.
They had a lot of children and the
Panther party was a,
there were a genuinely good people and
they were gangsters.
Um,
and the good people impressed me and
I'm,
one of them was running the school,
a school and they were jammed into a
brown shingle house in,
in Oakland.
I mean the,
they had double decker beds from one
wall to the other,
but the kids.
So I,
um,
I thought this Hollywood producer would
give me the money but it didn't turn out
that way,
but I raised a,
I think it was $125,000,
which a lot of money in those days and
bought a church at Baptist Church in
East Oakland that had been overtaken by
the,
uh,
inner city.
It was a white Baptist church.
And,
and I,
I signed up the check,
I created the Oakland community learning
center,
a five zero,
one c three to how's the school?
I'll never forget the,
uh,
the minister said to me as I handed him
the check,
I hope you're not going to turn this
over to the black panthers and the
nation of Islam.
When did he know that you were working
with them at all?
At the time?
That we had no idea.
It was literally,
I know I'm talking to you like most of
the left today.
I had no idea who they were,
the panthers.
Um,
but anyway,
I've told this story in a radical son,
my autobiography.
Anyway,
in 1974 I,
I recruited the bookkeeper,
my bookkeeper at ramparts to do the
books for the school because I believed
our own propaganda that the government
was racist and that they would shut down
the panthers if they didn't keep the
books,
which was ridiculous.
I mean,
look at Jesse Jackson,
look at Dale Sharpton.
Huge tax evader yeah.
And he's walking the streets because
he's progressive and Blackie's
protected.
Um,
and in December 1974,
uh,
betty disappeared and by the time the
police Fisher body out of San Francisco
Bay,
I knew the panthers had killed there and
I had been interviewed by the police.
They explained to me lots of things.
It's very difficult to high to dispose
of a body unless you have an
organization and then it's not so hard
you have safe houses and this and that.
Um,
and so when that happened,
I was personally devastated.
I mean,
I was in the same place.
My parents were being embarrassed by the
Khrushchev report,
something I swore that I would never
happened to me.
Um,
and I,
I'm curious,
what were your parents around at the
time?
Yeah,
my mother was very,
they were worried for my safety as they
should be.
I was threatened by Elaine Brown,
who was the head of the panthers and is
alive today,
a toasted by the Atlanta journal
Constitution.
And uh,
funded by actually conservatives have
often not always speak on college
campuses.
Um,
she was the head of the party.
Why would conservatives phoned her now
as she evolved?
I'd forget that.
What's the name of.
It's a big orange county foundation.
They gave her $10,000
to speak and uh,
I can't remember.
It was UC Santa Barbara.
I with the students there and informed
the now because,
uh,
conservatives in this country are a well
meaning a liberal minded people
generally,
especially the ones with money.
I'm giving you the benefit of the doubt.
I mean,
here's a black person claiming that
America is an oppressive country.
All sure he has money anyway.
Uh,
I was personally devastated.
I was clinically,
I would say clinically depressed for
seven or eight years where I wake up in
tears every morning.
I felt responsible for having recruited
betty.
Uh,
my name is Betty van patter.
The woman who was murdered.
She was a mother of three children.
I'm the etiology is so precious that on
the way to betty's funeral,
her daughter who worked for me and I
didn't know if she was 19 or 20 at the
time,
I tried to warn her.
I mean,
I was afraid for my children and I said,
I think the panthers killed your mother.
And her response was,
no,
they're good people.
So,
so I set out then to warn when I had
sort of assimilated all this,
uh,
I,
my mission was to warn other people and
that's how I know that Barack Obama is a
communist.
All right.
So wait,
let's,
let's pause before we jump to modern day
because everything that you just
described there was why I thought your
bio is so interesting because you grow
up with communists,
you know,
now I didn't know about the.
I didn't,
I didn't know about the guy in the
basement.
But you,
I mean,
you,
you are firmly on the left.
Your whole first 40 some ideas with
Maurice.
I wrote a book called Empire in
revolution,
which the left used,
right?
So leftist,
Communist,
Marxist.
I mean,
so bourbon for example,
um,
set of the,
of my book that it was like a,
I don't know what he said,
a handbook,
a Bible for the,
for the left before I,
he called me a renegade for leaving the
left.
Right,
right.
So that's.
So you're,
you're a hero.
But the second you now change.
Now,
of course,
if you deviate from the party line,
this is what political people don't
realize,
political correctness is
turn that Mousey tongue,
the greatest mass murder in human
history and vented to shut people up.
It's the party line.
If you deviate from the party line,
they throw you into the cold.
Yeah.
Alright.
So now we're,
let's flash forward.
Unless there's something that shoot you
or shoot you,
right.
So they,
they silence you,
then they shoot you,
you know,
uh,
so unless I'm missing something,
I think we can flash forward now to
around 85,
which is really when you,
um,
what happened was when this happened,
no,
I was writing,
I,
I had,
um,
left ramparts with Peter Collier who was
by buddy.
Uh,
and uh,
it was Peter's idea that to write a,
a dynastic biography.
Uh,
the goals were,
the saga was on pbs at the time,
so it was a generational saga.
So I was in the midst of writing a book
on the rockefellers,
which became a best seller.
And then we were asked to do a book on
the Kennedys,
which came out in 1985.
And,
uh,
in 19 eight and,
and,
uh,
when it came out it was a number one New
York Times bestseller and uh,
the Washington Post,
the editor of The Washington Post Sunday
magazine called me to pick my brain
about young Joe Kennedy was a
congressman and he said,
what have you guys been doing?
Our whole,
Oh,
you won't believe this,
but Peter and I just voted for Ronald
Reagan and neither Peter and I had
talked before casting that vote.
Wow.
Oh,
that's a good story.
You want to write it?
So our story was better run than red,
but he renamed it lefties for Reagan.
Right?
So then that's when the knives came out
and Peter said to me at the time,
I just show you how deep the current rot
the fake news is.
Um,
we were front page New York Times,
both books about the rockefellers and
Sunday Times.
And The New York Times sets the standard
for all the media they even reprint
them.
May View is.
But um,
and when our article came back on,
we voted for Reagan.
Peter said to me are literary careers
are over.
Wow.
Alright.
So you must be joking,
so you really had no idea.
I have no idea.
Even though you knew some of the
tactics,
but it was exactly right.
That was the end.
I don't lie less 20 bucks.
I'm a New York Times.
They noticed one and called me a relic
for using the word Communist.
That was just a squib.
Right.
So even though you knew all the tactics
that could be coming down on your way
and the way you be treated,
ever been a realist about that then.
So you.
So that's it.
You just weren't a realist and your own.
Even though you saw you had such a
history of seeing what would happen and
not the hare instant cognitivism black
could never believe that people can be
so ideological and so duped and I should
know.
Yeah,
I think I've been suffering from a
little of this right now and immediate.
The rubber's meeting the road with me at
the moment of of this kind of what,
but what was it about?
Was it something about Reagan or was it
really about Mondelez?
Reagan was.
This happened earlier.
My bumped in to the parking lot of the
Berkeley Co op,
which is a supermarket that was
everybody liked because it was a
cooperative.
Um,
we're not rolling stone actually publish
a story that Peter and I did on the
weather,
the weather underground,
telling the truth about it.
Um,
and uh,
this woman I knew that me and the
parking lot and she said,
David,
you know,
people really hate you.
Now.
The truth about these crazy terrorists
is what they were,
who got people killed and they hate you
now.
Hey me for saying the truth about it.
Yeah.
But,
but what was it about Reagan also that
then they hated Reagan the way they hate
trump.
Yeah.
It was the same kind of hatred.
That ticket,
they just hate it.
It's,
it's because he's,
he's not one of us.
That's,
it's very visceral.
Yeah.
Is that what anything?
Ironically,
yeah.
He's not one of them,
you.
No,
he was an,
he didn't know the trump phenomenon and
problem is a little different,
but it's not all that different.
I mean,
Reagan was an actor that they looked
down on that,
um,
you know,
a fun,
wrote a pamphlet called,
uh,
an essay which is a pamphlet called the
anti capitalist mentality.
Why do academics,
he capitalism,
why are they so left?
And the answer is because they feel
superior to businessmen.
And here's trump.
The businessman.
A businessman are,
yeah,
they have no respect for what it takes
to build a billion dollar empire of,
for them it's all theft or something
underhanded.
It's after it's crony capitalism.
We're.
So Reagan was like that.
He was an actor.
How dare he be present.
We're so much smarter than he is.
We should be running the country.
So intellectual stat,
I think it was about intellectual.
It's generally they don't,
they,
they feel that they're smarter than
everybody else because they haven't
actually created for the most part.
So they have to sort of elevate what the
pad.
I think the power should go to them.
And I learned very early when I was
still leftist when Jack Kennedy was
assassinated and Lyndon Johnson became
president.
I was living in England and of course
Europeans looked at on an Americans from
the beginning of the republic,
but um,
uh,
Lbj,
he had the Lbj cufflinks and the Lbj
children and the Lbj dogs and the MPG.
So they,
they just thought he was.
This is a,
yeah,
this is,
uh,
you know,
and Johnson was much smarter than Jack
Kennedy and he went to East Texas State
Teachers College,
but he,
he unfortunately,
he put in place the great society,
which is an Albatross on America's neck,
has been for lo these this half century.
But he was smart.
He knew how to get it through Congress
and Jack Kennedy couldn't get any of it
through.
Yeah.
I now congress barely worked.
So that's why when trump came along,
I wasn't one of these never trumping
inside the beltway snobs.
Although some of my,
my good friends from path,
okay,
so you have this final awakening.
You write this thing.
Then a year later,
I think in [inaudible] 86 year old,
why?
It wasn't why I left the left.
I wrote it and say,
look,
I,
as I say,
W,
I was personally threatened by Elaine
Brown.
Um,
and then in a,
I have a tape of the phone conversation
was he said,
if you,
if you should get run over David,
really,
I'm,
I'm going to be your best friend because
people will say I did it,
something like that.
I mean,
it was a threat.
Um,
so I was afraid I fed to Kate Coleman,
who wrote an article for a now defunct
leftwing magazine,
uh,
what's called the party's over about the
criminality of the panthers,
which I had discovered by personal
investigation.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
I forgot.
Well,
getting to the village voice piece,
the village voice.
Yeah.
So I finally in 1986,
which is,
it's a decade later,
I wrote a piece why I am not no longer a
leftist.
And uh,
and we've heard to this,
I did not name the killers,
but I did refer to the murder and the
path that the panthers and murdered her.
And I'm a poem.
Berman wrote this piece about the
renegade Horowitz,
the intellectual life,
and the renegade Horowitz.
That was a vicious attack and he had me
at the end of his piece cheering on
suicide.
Sita,
who was a psychopath.
That was a contract in Nicaragua who
might hadn't even heard of when he
called me,
he said in Horowitz's cheering wakes up
the next morning cheering suicide.
So basically you went off the
reservation officially with this article
and then you had said the knives were
already out.
We'll know it was with the Reagan
article with the Reagan article.
This is why this is a right and left.
Right.
So this was a way.
He was a year later,
right?
I think it was 85 and 86,
so a year later.
So the knives were already out and then
this was like sort of the final door on.
That's right.
And I saw 1986,
87.
That's 30 years ago.
Is that what it is?
Something like that.
In 30 years my work has never been taken
the work,
the ideas,
my arguments with the left.
Why am no law?
I wrote a long essay on,
on leaving the left,
um,
and why I left it a never responded to.
I'm the nation,
made one stab at it,
but I'm not a very good one.
On the other hand is like hundred
thousand attacks on me on the Internet
from leftists.
So it's not like they don't think that I
need to be refuted anything.
It's just more effective to pretending
it makes you feel any better.
Right before we sat down,
I was scrolling my twitter feed and some
article was written about me were they
referred to me as a right winger and
then got a few other things incorrect
about me and then my own audience
actually started attacking them on
twitter and then they,
they didn't issue a retraction,
but they changed the headline at least
and change one other thing,
which of course is not journalistically
sound,
but I guess maybe I'm picking up some of
the.
Well at first it hurts,
but eventually you get to be liable.
Proof thing.
They libel used so much that it just
seems ridiculous more than anything
else.
It's just lazy,
Lazy and ridiculous.
So you know,
I'm an easier target than you are
because I vowed when I left the left
that I'm gonna talk to the left.
Address them in the same way that they
addressed everybody else.
No.
Oh,
I didn't know you could have nicely.
Yeah.
You and barry very hard to demonize.
I'm sort of easy.
So when you see,
you had some nice things to say about me
when you sat down and when you see
someone like me that's understands the
title of this book,
that understands your journey and all
that.
Do you think I was just.
Even though I'm obviously are we have 30
some odd years between us that I was
just late to the game and picking up
what was going on here?
Or do you think something also happened
in the last couple of years with the
left?
Alright.
First of all,
starting with the mcgovern campaign.
That's when it started.
The communists left,
infiltrated and took over the Democratic
Party.
Um,
I mean Tom Hayden was no longer with us,
was a cynical and I am American,
lying radical.
Uh,
and he was given the medal of freedom by
Bill Clinton.
Um,
uh,
he was a state legislator in the state
of California.
You can still see his work whenever you
see prop 65 that warns you about the bad
effects of chemicals in your whatever.
Oh yeah.
It's everywhere here in la.
Um,
but the Democratic Party took the left
in the,
the Ana,
the Nih,
American totalitarian,
and I would say racist.
Left.
I will explain that later.
But racist left was taken into the bosom
of the Democratic Party in the Clinton
administration.
And with Obama,
they got one of theirs in the White
House.
Okay.
So let's.
So let's pause there for a second.
So when I hear you said about the
Clinton administration,
that's hard for me to picture because
those eight years were basically,
I don't think we saw a lot of what we're
seeing right now.
So what am I missing?
If you miss them?
You didn't know the personalities from
one.
Um,
I've written a,
let's put it this way.
I think back to the Clinton
administration very fondly still that
things were basically,
there were terrible that they were
basic.
Bill Clinton's was not an idiot log in
the way that Hillary Clinton,
this Bill Clinton's etiology was.
Why was this ideology and was.
But that you would argue that's probably
a saving grace.
Then corruption is far better than
communism.
Yeah.
If it burned for the corruption of the
Clintons,
Bernie Sanders would have been a
nominee.
Um,
that's a great quote there.
You just go out corruption as far better
than communism as a good way because it
is because you've got a meeting that you
can deal with.
It doesn't have the ideology that sweeps
people along with Bill Clinton
domestically was,
uh,
a fairly centrist,
you know,
I don't have too much to quarrel with
them.
They are,
uh,
I'm foreign policy was terrible.
Absolutely terrible.
The World Trade Center was blown up in
1993 a by Ramzi Yousef.
He intended to kill 50,000
people or $200,000,
top of one of the towers on the other.
The bomb is fired.
It wounded a thousand people and killed
six.
Bill Clinton never visited the site,
dismissed it as an individual criminal
act when it was inspired by the blind
sheikh who's just been,
um,
assignment been London.
We should have been stopped in the
nineties before the World Trade Center
was.
I mean,
I can't go.
I've written a lot about this.
So,
but in the case of that in case the
first World Trade Center bombing.
So what do you think was going on?
They didn't Bill Clinton's head.
So this happens.
He never visited.
Say what is the,
what's the ideology there that would
lead him to that?
It's an interesting question.
I wish we had a one of these Democrats
on and you could ask them the question.
Um,
I'll,
I'll try to get a former just to skip
ahead in this book.
I've written big agenda.
I,
I lay out what I think is going on that,
that,
uh,
the Democratic Party is now a racist
party.
Uh,
you used the phrase people of color is a
racist phrase.
Identity politics is racist and it's
anti American.
The fundamental American idea is that
we're all creatures of a divinity or
maybe nature's God,
whatever Jefferson wrote there and equal
in the eyes of our creator.
Therefore we should be treated equally
by our government and we have rights
that are inalienable at government can't
take away.
So it's all about individual freedom.
And most importantly,
individual accountability.
When I was a kid in public schools,
we always,
there was this phrase,
regardless of race,
color,
or creed,
who an American is somebody who doesn't
look at your origins.
We're a nation of immigrants that way.
Don't look at your origins.
Of course,
if you come from a terrorist country,
we should have a little vetting process.
Um,
identity politics is the opposite.
What the left seeks.
We are in a civil war situation now.
Um,
and the reason is the reason it's so
irreconcilable is that the left believe
is a racist that believes in a racial
hierarchy.
So if you're the right skin color,
which is dark,
you go to the head of the line for
admissions to college and go to the head
of the line for job.
You go to the headline for our
promotion,
you go to the head of the line for
almost anything and everything's not
diverse enough.
So we'll take.
Um,
so what would you say to the people that
would say,
well,
white people had a good for a long time
and,
and why?
People do bad things and they did good
things.
And one of the good things that White
America did was to liberate the slaves.
People forget that we inherited slavery.
This is how I've been myself,
notorious in the left by coming out
against reparations for slavery a 137
years after the fact.
Um,
America inherited a system of slavery.
Slavery existed.
I learned this from Orlando Patterson,
who is a black left of center,
a sociologist at Harvard who's written
prize winning books on slavery and
freedom.
Slavery existed for 3000 years.
Nobody ever said it was a moral,
not Jesus,
not Moses,
not aristotle until a white Christian
males in England led by Wilberforce,
said it's a moral and an American slave
owner.
Thomas Jefferson wrote it into the birth
certificate of this country that all men
are created equal and a given right to
liberty by their creator.
Within 20 years,
the slave trade was ended.
Um,
the reason that America didn't initiate
a civil war in 1776 to free the slaves.
What are the biggest reasons was that
England would have come and just,
we take in the colonies and reinstituted
a slavery anyway,
and within a generation or a little more
given in those days,
people live shorter lives,
uh,
at the cost of a 350,000
union soldiers.
We the braid that the slaves and
liberated them throughout the
hemisphere.
So black people,
Americans can be very proud of their
heritage.
Um,
you know,
it's,
it's a human heritage,
so it's got a lot of bad spots,
but you look at any other country in the
world,
and uh,
forgive me,
left this for saying this one thing nice
about America is the best.
What other country do Asians get in
boats and risk their lives to get into?
You think that coming here to be
oppressed,
right?
I mean everybody,
everybody wants to be here,
and then the funny thing is this,
at the same time,
you go to watch some of these protests
and the people that are screaming about
how racist and evil and patriarchy and
all this stuff,
they're also the ones calling for open
borders.
They want everyone to share in the heart
that is to destroy the country.
Anybody with any sense knows so had it
all.
But let me just say,
yeah,
the left is,
is it,
it's own.
Whatever ideas it has to marks.
It's the Marxist paradigm of the
oppressors and the oppressed and it's an
economic.
It begins as an economic and they've
layered on race and gender.
Um,
so the fact is determines a country's
prosperity is culture,
not classes.
It's culture.
America has a great culture.
We take in.
I'm.
One of the things we do is we take in
brilliant people from all over the world
and give them freedom to innovate.
Other countries,
copy our innovations.
And Israel is the same way.
It's why they hate it because they're
bringing in people from all over the
windows.
But also it's the freedom people do not
appreciate freedom in this country,
obviously,
since we are universities and now
totalitarian institutions,
I can't go to a university without
bodyguards.
Yeah.
And that's been true for the last 15
years I've been physically attack.
If I didn't have bodyguards and if the
university has put in place security,
I could never get through a speech and
I'm not alone.
It's any conservative,
virtually any conservative.
And now it's moderates and this is
fascism and that's a.
it's totally embedded in our university
system.
Yeah.
Do you make a distinction between sort
of the leaders who really understand the
stuff that you're talking about?
So the people who,
who are the leaders of this leftist
movement versus the,
the bulk of the people who I think are
following along without bad intentions,
like when I see all these kids who I,
you know,
I lock them on twitter and people got a
demonstration to get laid.
Yeah.
You know,
and people are gullible and they don't
think.
And I can't put two and two together.
The phrase I didn't want to skip this.
People of color is a racist phrase.
It's not English.
Do we say,
here's a box of crayons of color and
French.
That's the way French people or color or
whatever they say.
Yeah.
So it's a completely ideological
construct.
So is that as its function?
Well,
let's look at the Mexico.
Two main ethnic groups.
The descendants of the Spanish
conquistadores who slaughtered the
indigenous Indians and the descendants
of the indigenous Indians.
When they crossed the border,
they both people of color,
therefore they're oppressed.
Both of them.
The keys,
the doors and the indigenous people,
they are oppressed.
They deserve special sensitivities and
special privileges.
Maharajahs in India are people of color
be headers in Rocca are people of color
who are people of color,
white people,
white people are evil,
bad.
And this is,
this is,
this is the racist ideology of our time.
Is it also lacking in several other
ways?
I mean,
for example,
you could take American Indians,
uh,
people who've moved here from India or
their grandparents moved here from
India,
or you could take Asian people at
virtually any nationality
and they don't count in this leftist
thing because they've said,
well,
the Indians happened.
Yeah.
The native Americans.
I'm sorry,
not.
I thought that was ridiculous.
Now I'm going to,
we're not going to edit that out because
I don't believe in that,
but that was in the completely idiotic
statement.
I American Indians from India who moved
to America.
That's what native American,
correct?
Yeah.
Correct.
Chinese,
the Japanese and American Indians in
that native American.
That's correct.
Yeah.
I just ruined my list.
I don't like to say says my Nora.
No,
don't look over your shoulder.
There's only,
there's only arrows coming.
That was Indian joke right there.
I'm in the,
the left.
It's pathetic.
Intellectually.
They don't have an argument.
So they have to purge those groups
because those groups.
Yeah.
That's why they have to shut you up
because they can't deal with your
arguments is really simple,
straightforward,
and it's so invaded our literary
culture.
The last two national book awards were
given to racist tracks,
one by Ta-nehisi coats I can never
remember.
The title of it was just a rank racist
coats.
Uh,
what inspired him to write the book?
It's about how evil America is,
but how was the murder of his friend?
Not The bird.
I the killing of his friend by a
policeman in Maryland.
It turns out as he tells you that the
policemen,
the policemen accused the dead,
his dead friend of trying to run him
over with his car.
The policeman is black.
So what does code say?
He was thinking white.
Now that isn't the purest racism and
this one now it's called stamped from
the beginning.
It's a semi illiterate book that,
that it,
that they have lowered their standards
so dramatically as a still shocks me
because these are intelligent people
that people give the awards,
but I should know better.
Um,
but it opens with the police shootings
of criminals in the last year,
which were totally distorted by black
lives matter and other leftists into a
cops gutting down unarmed blacks.
These were predators.
And who did they pray?
Pray on a braid on black people.
Freddie Gray.
I mean,
you know,
you could go on a,
again,
even remember the names,
the guy in Ferguson,
um,
they're criminals who prey on black
people,
but this guy has them as innocent blacks
who were gunned down by racist cops.
So at the opening of his book,
which is which he has called the
definitive history of racism in America,
he's exposed as a liar and he won the
national book.
So our institutions have been just
generally corrupted.
Yeah.
So what is this racist ideology of the
left?
So for a lot of people hearing this,
I think a certain amount of people
hearing this,
we're going to go,
yeah,
I get it.
So you don't talk quite like this,
which is why I think you're much harder
to,
uh,
I'm,
I'm wanting to see you with a so called
liberal.
I don't call them liberals.
They're bigots.
Yeah.
Well,
I've had many progressive,
a progressive on this show and I treat
them with the same respect that I treat
anybody else I did.
My general rule is I don't find that
braiding somebody or belittling them,
but yeah,
I made this bow ready 30 years ago that
I was going to berate the left.
I was going to say,
Hey Lbj,
how many kids did you kill today?
I actually,
when I was still sort of leaving the
left,
I thought about that statement a lot.
St.
Let's see if I were a prisoner of war
and I was in a room with my captor,
would I rather it was Lbj or holcim and
it was a no brainer,
so that's part of it is that you just
constantly say the worst thing about
your intellectual opponents because
there's no end here that you just
constantly say anything to you and
that's why I love Milo because he just
throws it right back in their face and
that's what really needs to be done.
These people need to be embarrassed.
Alloying probably beyond embarrassment.
Yeah,
I mean ABC news stuff.
Annapolis is sitting there with Katrina
Vanden who oval,
whose entire life has been spent
apologizing for defending and advancing
communists causes.
That was that.
That's ABC.
That's how far gone this country is.
So are all the answers then for you on
the right or do you have frustrations
with the right?
Because I think right before we started,
we only talked for about 30 seconds.
Liberal.
I've,
I tried to,
um,
no,
I mean I,
I get know what did I.
Oh,
I,
I took on the leaders of the religious
right over a mark raw rash cope was the
governor of Montana and was the chairman
of the RNC,
met with the thing that's called the
human rights association,
which is a gay group.
And he addressed them or whatever.
I met with them and he was denounced by
Paul.
Why Rick and very well known leaders of
the religious right.
And I wrote an article saying that I'm a
political party is not a religious
movement or shouldn't be and it's the
job of the RNC chair to reach out and,
and,
and so forth.
And I've never been an opponent of gay
marriage and I,
you know,
I could go on on.
Yeah.
And you mentioned before that abortion,
you're,
although you're not a fan to say the
least,
but you are a pro choice,
right?
So,
no,
I wouldn't describe myself as pro
choice.
Okay.
I,
um,
and it's been a long lifetime of
rethinking this issue when I grew up,
uh,
abortions were illegal after the third
month and we know a lot more now and
medical techniques where we just know a
lot more about fetuses and the,
you know,
if you think about it,
their children from conception.
I mean,
I just,
it's not an argument as a person
already.
Um,
do you think from the moment of women,
it's not about the woman's body alone,
uh,
you know,
I,
I think that fathers are involved as
well,
but certainly this child there,
so you know,
the argument against it as you want to
bring a kid into the world that's going
to have a absolutely miserable life
because it's wrong parent at the wrong
time.
You know,
and I,
I think the energy should be spent on
finding ways to take care of children
that the parents are unable to take care
of it.
It's a very vexed problem and I don't,
I've,
I've confronted a right winger is
actually was in the heritage foundation
debate,
you know who said it's murder?
I said,
well,
if you think it's murder,
then you should be demanding.
The execution of every mother in America
has had an abortion and if you don't,
it's a much more complicated problem,
so that's kind of where I am.
What was his response to that and shine
them up?
That has a real quite well.
That's why the abortion went to me is is
one where I think very good people on
both sides of this are just struggling
with it because it almost is coming down
to the basic questions of life and it
is,
but you can't discuss basic questions in
our political atmosphere and not with
the left.
The left wants to convert everything
into a morality play where they are.
Right.
How much of this is culture?
Did you see that change to that?
It's just.
I know what you're saying,
that culture is the most important
thing,
but when did it go from,
like I was thinking,
even left,
started taking over the universities in
the seventies now and they've got the k
12 schools as well.
Um,
and you know,
I conducted a was literally five or six
year campaign to try to get a,
an economic bill of rights,
really a student bill of rights that
students have a right to a professional
education and a democracy that means
that they have professors can express
their opinions but they have to present
the opposing sides of controversial
issues in a fair minded way.
And I was attacked from one end of the
country.
Other is a Torquemada and a controller.
It's very liberal.
And
I did it all out of their own documents.
There's a very famous academic freedom
statement that was drawn.
Well,
what's the thought control part of
trying to get more in there?
Don't you know,
he can't be logic.
This is the aup.
These are stalinists.
I mean I debated them across the
country.
They,
gosh,
I mean they put me through the ringer,
but you know,
like I say,
he'd get to a point where you're liable
proof because they've liable you so
much,
and it does,
it does,
but they fought it tooth and nail.
And for example,
I had praised,
uh,
in all of my speeches,
this is a 1915,
the statement on academic freedom by the
American Association of university
professors and the Penn state still has
or had as its academic freedom
provision,
the statement that the obligate the,
it is not the place of a professor in a
democratic society to indoctrinate his
or her students.
Therefore they must present divergent
opinions in a fair minded manner.
That's a paraphrase of and I praise
that.
And so the head of the Aup,
Carrie Nelson,
I made it a personal crusade to get that
ripped out of the Penn state academic
freedom.
So the so called liberal person right
now this to be removed.
He's alive.
Okay.
Yeah,
carry.
He actually,
I mean he's defended me in some places,
so he's like an,
an whatever.
It is.
Not quite a bit a doctrinaire,
but he did the faculty senate.
They're ripped it out and took out
explicitly the thing.
It's not the place to indoctrinate the
student.
Yeah.
Do you find when you,
when you meet people,
maybe some young people that are waking
up to some of this stuff at once,
they see one piece of it that the rest
of it crumbles.
Right?
Exactly.
Because I see this because I saw it
happen with myself obviously,
and I,
and for me it's still an unfolding
process I think.
And that's why I'm happy to have these
conversations,
but I see it happening with other
people.
Now.
I get emails every day.
People would be like,
one little thing happened and then
months later I now believe everything
that was Steve Miller says it was guns.
That's what turned him from a liberal
and conservative.
Um,
I have,
uh,
somebody who writes occasionally for
front page website,
uh,
who
let me speak in Camden,
New Jersey.
And I pointed out,
as I said I do in my book,
big agenda.
Um,
every inner city of any size is 100
percent controlled by the Democratic
Party and progressive it has been for 50
to 100 years.
Clinton,
Camden.
So every little walkie Atlanta,
Chicago,
St Louis,
Baltimore,
right?
Um,
everything that's wrong in the inner
cities that policy can affect Democrats
and progressives are responsible for,
once you see that it's all over.
And then there are people out there
screaming that.
And even president,
we had this.
Here's some leftist mentality when Peter
Collier and I wrote the bestseller on
the Kennedys,
we found ourselves in a green room,
have a good morning.
America sitting.
There were only three people.
The other person was William F Buckley
and was dead silence in the room.
And uh,
the reason that Peter and I were silent
as we,
we had no idea who buckley was.
We just knew we didn't want to be nice
to a fascist.
That's what the left and called him a
fascist.
We didn't want to be nice to a fascist.
So Peter broke the ice by saying,
my mother is a big fan of yours.
And then we find out from Buckley who
was a very gracious human being,
um,
that he was silent because his son had
just written a very critical attack on a
Kennedy book.
That was another one that came out and
he didn't know if it was.
Huh?
Uh,
civility on the left.
Yeah.
It just,
it's so,
it's fascist.
That's what it is.
And if this,
there's no way.
I mean,
the only response you can have this one,
like Milo's it just go in their face.
But anyways,
I just shot you down.
Yeah.
There is a,
uh,
an incredible video that I saw a couple
of years ago have you at University of
San Diego I think.
And a young Muslim student gets out,
very articulate with a head scarf.
Yeah.
And she,
at first she opens by thanking you for
coming and saying she's sarcastic.
Diversity of thought and people can
watch it and we'll link to it below so
people can actually watch the video.
There's a weighing of sarcasm in it or,
or it was either sarcasm or she was
trying to butter you up before she went
to kill.
Uh,
can you explain the rest of what
happened there?
So that,
I don't know.
Yeah.
Then edit it.
She said I'm falsely accused the Muslim
Students Association of being a front
for the Muslim Brotherhood,
which it is and Hamas.
So,
and,
and we had distributed a pamphlet
showing this.
Um,
so I,
instead of arguing whether about whether
the Muslim Students Association students
for Justice in Palestine,
they're both amongst friends,
Brotherhood Fronts A.
instead of arguing with her,
I just decided to cut to the chase.
I said,
will you condemn a Mohs as a terrorist
organization?
And she said,
uh,
you want to crucify me company?
Oh,
I don't know how I respond to coming in.
And she said,
well,
if I don't condemn Hamas then I will be
arrested by the Department of Homeland
Security.
This is how delusional these people are.
So I changed the question.
I had done this at other.
So I knew what to expect.
I said,
let me put it to you this way.
I'm a Jew and the head of his bullet
says he wants us choose to gather in
Israel.
So he won't have to hunt us down
globally for it or against it.
She leaned into the microphone and said
for it,
and she was dependent afterwards by the
Muslim Students Association.
A whole left.
Hey genocidal.
They want to kill the Jews.
When she said that,
I suspect you were not shocked as
insanely shocking as that sounds.
No,
because I had it at UC Santa Barbara.
I asked the same question of the head of
the Muslim Students Association when he
said it was too complicated a question
for a yes.
No answer.
Right?
Genocides.
Too complicated.
He was smarter than she was.
Hers was just like,
hers was just showing you what they
think and what they want.
So.
All right,
so let's,
let's shift
to Islam then.
I,
I've been talking about it and I've
tried to bring on.
I brought on liberals to talk about it.
I've had,
you know,
very measured people like Sam Harris,
quote pupils.
I've had ion Hirsi Ali on who talks
about her own personal enemies on the
left.
People who are at my new eyes,
who's a Muslim,
you know,
is still a leftist liberal.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's a liberal,
he's a liberal.
Whether that I don't want to speak for
him,
I don't get into any extra trouble.
Um,
but I've had.
My point is that I've had plenty of
people thought of as liberals or on the
left discuss it.
They get hate from the left.
Then I've had people more on the right
talk about it,
such as Lauren Southern and Ben Shapiro
and some others that of course they're
going to get a certain amount of hate
for it.
How do you gauge how much of a problem
this actually is
at the moment?
The problem being the problem being
Islamic extremism
where God or whatever you call it,
I think Islam is a problem and no
rational person could not look at Islam
and say it's not a problematic religion.
It preaches hatred against all other
religions.
It's sanctions.
There's just a series of quotes from the
Korean sanctions where they're beheading
infidels,
which is what we are.
I'm the Prophet Mohammed has has said
that the day of judgment will only come
when the Muslims fight the Jews and
killed them when the Jews behind the
rocks and the trees and the rocks and
the trees cry out.
Oh,
Muslim descent.
You hiding behind me.
Come and kill it.
Yeah.
Talk.
Not only.
Yeah,
by organized Islam.
Uh,
but it's repeated use of our Kara
doorway.
I'm set as much.
The Holocaust was a punishment and on
Gypson TV and he is the [inaudible],
the leading man.
Not only put the bustle of brotherhood,
but for whom Aberdeen,
Hillary's righthand.
That's her man.
That the Holocaust was God's punishment
of the Jews for their corruption.
And it will come again.
Uh,
this time,
Allah willing at the hands of the
believers is a genocidal.
Nancy is Garrett Dally,
and he's the image of Hillary Clinton's
right hand and deputy,
but in charge of bustle of affairs for
the State Department.
Yeah,
it's a big problem.
Not a little one.
Yeah.
So Keith Ellison is the Muslim
Brotherhood.
A candidate is now the number two guy in
the Democratic Party,
only missed by 13 boats.
How could the Democratic Party embraced
this?
And Tom Perez is no better,
but at least that'll.
Allison has an open record,
uh,
but you know,
being in bed with the Muslim
Brotherhood,
being supported by them and being a
Farah can,
Jew hater and America Hainer and white
hater.
I'm on what happened to the Democratic
Party.
Yeah,
I mean in America and stuff is amazing
because even in the last couple of days,
I don't follow,
fabricate,
verified Milo's not on twitter anymore,
but I was looking at fire cannons,
twitter feed or something got retweeted
into my feed.
I mean,
it's all God will destroy America.
Haydel the Jews hate white people
for 11 years.
The spokesman for the nation of Islam.
And you know,
people have to repudiate what they did
that,
this is,
this is why I say Barack Obama is a
communist.
He was raised by communists.
He,
his whole political career until he
became United States senator was in the
Communists,
left.
Uh,
I mean,
I know these people.
Um,
if you are a part of a movement that you
know is evil,
the first thing you want to do is warn
other people about it,
especially when it's so deceptive.
It talks about social justice and all
this crap anyway.
No,
well,
I mean he hasn't.
So that's how you know what his
allegiances are.
And when you asked me about the,
this was earlier in our conversation
about why,
why is the Democratic Party so soft on
Islamic terrorists?
There are people of color that has to
play a big role.
The first thing you do is all we have to
understand if they're killing people,
it must be because we did something
very sick.
Yeah.
What is that self flagellation that so
many people in the West have guilt.
I mean,
steel is really guilty of success
has written a whole book called white
guilt.
Yeah.
It'll bring down our,
our great civilization if it's the,
you know,
and we haven't talked about Donald
Trump.
Yeah.
Objective my book.
Okay.
So let's,
I think is,
I think if we have an antidote,
he's,
is it?
So you really believe that that trump
and that,
you know,
was gonna say a second
ago when you were talking about,
you know,
fighting the roots of Islamic extremism.
I mean,
Bannon,
from what I understand,
seems to be the architect of that.
That is a good guy.
Steve Bennett.
Yeah.
So you don't believe him to be an anti
Semite though.
First of all,
the chief evidence,
there's evidence given that Steve Bannon
is an anti Semite one is a disgruntled
wife in the middle of a divorce
proceeding,
a custody case who said who claim that
he said that Jewish children are whiny,
which melt way.
Well,
be the case of,
you know,
the whole ritual of Bar Mitzvahs you
shower a 13 year old with tons of money
and give them an audience of adults.
Okay.
So they might be allowed to deal with.
They might be whining,
right?
Um,
but that's certainly not true.
Waiting,
right?
Regardless,
even if even if it did,
that's not,
you'd have a big deal.
His wife that over the kids and when
they go to school and maybe the school
was very expensive.
There's an expensive school.
The archer school,
the other evidence is an article that I
wrote.
I gave the title tooth bill,
Kristol,
Republican spoiler,
renegade Jew,
so people who haven't read your.
I read the article,
I did not find anything and he's no read
a gay because he,
he's going to return Houma Aberdeen and
Ben Rhodes,
who was the architect,
uh,
one of the architects of the Iran deal
back to power.
It's a death knell for Israel.
I mean,
what they've done,
and not to mention the United I ran
isn't powerful enough to destroy the
United States,
but it's leaders do chant,
lead,
chance of death to America.
That's what they believe.
Why if Franklin Roosevelt gave nuclear
weapons to Hitler,
what will we call them?
Obama is an American trader and that's
because he's a communist and always has
been and always will be.
So I know enough people are going to
watch it and go,
wait a minute,
but the deal says that they can't get
new,
but you would say,
well,
it expires one.
It expires to the effect of the deal was
to lift the sanctions,
bring a ran back into the community of
nations.
He gave them $200,
billion dollars,
$200,
billion.
100.
I forget all the payments and there's no
controls.
But even if there were controls,
why would you bring them out of
isolation?
Now?
Ran is running over the Middle East.
They overthrew the government in Yemen,
which is why we now are losing American
lives,
their mind.
Anyway.
So if some of the.
So that's why I sought that crystal and
I didn't attack crystal during,
during the campaign,
you know,
look,
I,
you know,
I can see Donald trump.
I can see why he upset some people.
Yeah,
I can see how in my view they're
exaggerated,
you know,
the whatever,
the fears that I,
you know,
I don't think it per second that he's
anti Mexican or a bigoted in any way.
Um,
and it,
you know,
and I'm,
I'm one of those people that says,
well,
like he's been in public life for 30
years.
He didn't become a racist and until he
was running against a Democrat for
crying out tears,
uh,
I,
so I,
but I,
I could see a lot of people would get
bent out of shape during the campaign,
but once he's the nominee,
then it's him or hillary.
And if it's Hillary,
it's whom I aberdeen.
I mean it's,
you know,
the whole anti Israel crew.
So you can sympathize then with bill.
Crystal is intense.
So Bill Kristol,
who wanted conservatism,
Ole,
you know,
what's thought of as relied real
conservative.
These are,
these are people treating politics as a
religion.
Yeah,
if you don't refer to the United States
is a constitutional republic
conservative if you don't use the phrase
limited government,
limited government.
He never said that,
that I know what he's doing now.
I mean,
he's cutting the government and a big.
So there'll be.
I mean,
it's just crazy.
He won me over this way.
I mean,
I was nervous about him through the
campaign because you don't know,
uh,
you know,
this is his first venture into politics.
I don't know.
I'm not nervous about him anymore,
although I think he'll disappoint me on
some things,
but he won me over in the first debate.
Here's a guy,
he's never been a political candidate
before,
is on a platform with a 12 of the top
Republicans in the country is in front
of.
I don't remember if it's 30 million
people or whatever it is and the front
and he gets the first question because
he has the highest percentage in the
polls and it's not a question.
It's an attack from a beggar and Kelly,
you called women fat pigs,
slobs and dogs,
and he says,
oh,
that was just rosie o'donnell.
I said,
this guy is a guy.
They can intimidate because political
correctness is a party line.
As I said,
it comes from now,
let's say like a Communist Party line.
It shuts you up.
There is no other Republican under the
sun who on national TV this time in
front of 50 million people would elect
Hillary Clinton in the eye and said,
you're a liar and a crook even though
she's both.
If it were a male,
they would say it.
Why?
Because because there's this gigantic
double standard,
it's politically incorrect to say
anything critical about a woman.
This is ridiculous.
If that's the case,
they shouldn't be in politics.
Now I've left.
We'll just take that phrase,
but you can't be protected and at the
same time pretend to be strong.
You know,
it's interesting how pernicious some of
this stuff is because I'll even see
sometimes if if a,
if a man attacked me on twitter,
not that twitter fights are that
important,
but I'll immediately defend myself and
come back and I've had a few instances
where women have and I've just ignored
it because I don't want to attack a
woman and I know that's my own.
Then that's just my own reflection of
what we've all been schooled in that and
then there's penalties.
You have to think quickly about what the
consequences are,
so that desire to punch back or to not
be held hostage by political correctness
or I said,
would you argue that that is far more
important than any of his political?
Totally.
That's what I saw.
Here's a guy who the Democrats can
intimidate.
Look,
I use this phrase in my speeches,
whenever I see a Republican square off
against the Democrat,
it looks to me like Godzilla vs Bambi
because the Republican,
the Democrat is going to call the
Republicans are racist or sexist or
homophobic and Islamophobic,
and the Republican will call the
Democrat a liberal who's going to win
that argument.
So this is a bulldozer or,
but I love the way they call trump a
blitzkrieg.
The Democrat blitzkrieg.
Uh,
we have a tradition in this country.
It's sacred to a democracy of a
honeymoon for an incoming president.
It says there's a peaceful transition of
power.
It says we're all part of one community
since we're going to see what you do
have that will free to criticize you.
And the remedy is the next election.
Trump didn't get seven seconds,
he didn't get confirmation hearings.
He got a witch hunt.
The,
and this is another example of how
political correctness works.
A Jeff sessions,
I've known him for 20 years,
and I've known a lot of senators,
one of a handful of the most decent
human decent human beings in the senate.
A champion of civil rights,
this was an attorney general and the
deep South say state who prosecuted the
Ku Klux Klan,
who desegregated the schools and there's
Elizabeth Warren calling him a racist
and then violating Senate rules to
repeat calling him a racist,
and when she's told to shut up,
they say,
oh,
they're silencing another woman.
Yeah.
I tell effect of political correctness.
Is it just to be clear for people that
they didn't follow that whole thing?
She was reading other people's words,
which isn't technically allowed in the
sentence so that she was doing something
that she wasn't allowed to do by their
own rules exam.
Everyone turned it into a letter from
Coretta Scott King that she was
repudiated.
What happened was in Alabama there were,
there were three blacks who,
who's were defrauded of their voting
rights because they were in opposition
to three other blacks who were NACP
corrupt officials.
That's the whole case and and a sessions
didn't know how to defend himself the
first time he was up in the eighties.
I mean,
this is a thing.
Republicans are not used to fighting
back that you're used to getting out of
the way.
Why wouldn't you if people are calling
you racist,
sexist,
homophobic,
so it's obvious to me that that stuff is
not working as much anymore.
So then my last question,
given that that is amazing,
right?
So the words aren't,
but what I now think is we're going to
see more violence because they've been
pinned into a corner where everyone that
they're against is a Nazi and a racist
and all those things.
So I suspect we're going to see more
violence.
But my last question to you is with this
evolution with,
with now the first Republican,
as you were saying with trump,
that's not going to take it.
What's the good path now?
Like what if you could see something
good coming out of these next couple of
years?
What is that path?
No,
I am a Antonio Gramsci won't said that
the revolutionary for the revolutionary
must have pessimism of the intellect and
optimism of the will and I think he
stole that from somebody or I can't.
I can't remember who,
but I think he did it.
It's in wikipedia.
Well,
if it's in Wikipedia,
but definitely stolen from somebody,
I um,
yeah,
I,
you know,
my head was telling me there's nothing
is good.
Is gonna come and you know,
and you can see,
I mean,
there's so many,
so many problems of,
you know,
as I pointed out in,
in,
in my,
in my book,
big agenda,
the left,
the Democratic Party.
Uh,
it's a totalitarian party now.
It lied to get obamacare and lied about.
You can keep your doctor lied about,
you can keep your plan.
And it,
and its mission was control.
It's a credible assault on individual
freedom.
The government tells you you have to
have insurance.
have,
you have,
what are they for packages.
This is the kind of insurance you have
to have.
And the government gets all your health
information.
That is a totalitarian threat right
there.
But Republicans,
they're lame.
Why aren't they saying that?
So replacing Obamacare is obviously,
um,
you know,
as,
as we're speaking and Republicans are
all in disarray.
Um,
I dunno,
I don't know what's going to happen of
trump is fairly isolated.
You have all these conservative idiots
like crystal,
um,
and make mullen gunning for him.
A Republicans marched to the tune of
their own set of traumas all the time
were individualist.
I was amazed when the tea party came in
and held a demonstration in Washington
before that you couldn't get three
Republicans to march together because
they look at each other and say,
what are we collecting this?
So does that.
Then Eric said it was the last question,
but we'll keep going for a bit.
So there's that though.
So when the tea party organized and the
tea party was gaining momentum,
everyone was saying there were these
redneck back race,
very decent people who cleaned up after
themselves.
That's just destructive.
Nobody was hurt.
There was no violence.
Cops this,
when people start referring to the left
as fascists and not liberals,
then I'll say,
okay,
we're winning now.
Right now it isn't happening.
They go on.
They,
like I say,
I mean,
it's corrupted our culture.
It's corrupted our schools.
Uh,
I just very,
very bad.
But I think,
you know,
I,
my faith isn't Steve Bannon and Stephen
Miller.
These are two fighters and trump and
trump understands instinctively that
when you get attacked,
you attack back and throw them off.
Well,
I,
I have this phrase that I,
I picked up from Chris Lehane is a
democratic,
uh,
was in the New York Times article about
him,
a democratic strategists,
but he,
he stole it from Mike Tyson,
which is everybody has a game plan until
you punch them in the mouth.
And the Democrats have a massive punch
in the mouth for Republicans calling
them racists and Republicans at the
Comeback and Democrats.
The Democratic Party is the party of
racism.
It's the party of racial categories.
It's the party of identity politics.
It's the party of the inner cities.
It is a racist party.
It is also,
and I loved this,
but what trump said in the was in the
second debate,
he turned to the cameras and said,
you have to understand Hillary has
tremendous hatred in her heart.
And what he was referring to was the
basket of deplorables,
which he named.
She identified all of her opponents or
whatever.
Half it was.
The same thing,
um,
are racist,
sexist,
homophobes,
Islamophobes.
Xenophobes,
you name it and he's raised them up.
There isn't a conservative or a
deviating liberal who hasn't been in an
argument with a so called liberal who
hasn't been called a racist or sexist or
homophobic to in a way that was a gift.
The Democratic Party is a party of hate.
That's what they run on.
Everything they're doing now is,
is hate invent conspiracy theories with
the Russians.
I mean this from a party who's candidate
turned over 20 percent of America's
uranium reserves that are Russians.
I mean,
how do you deal with that?
The only way and politics.
You have a nine second soundbite.
Just go for the juggler.
Well,
I hope I don't want you.
I,
I like your style.
I want to see if we can convert people
at way.
Yeah.
Well I think interesting,
isn't it?
I think interestingly,
people or can be converted on both sides
because I think what's happening is I,
I know for sure that I've helped a lot
of progressives realized what true
liberalism is and at the same time I
think I've had and I know that I've
gotten a lot of more conservative people
to realize that not all liberals are
bad.
And I think that's where most of us
actually are.
That's good.
I don't want to take anything away from
you,
but I,
I found
when I came into the right,
I conservatives are generally very
decent people.
And when I criticize the religious right
leadership,
I had different reactions from things
like the Family Research Council.
I had people in my face,
blood vessels popping screaming at me.
Um,
and I had people who were very
supportive,
very Christian,
uh,
and that way.
And I also had this experience in the
2008.
I was at the moral majority,
uh,
Ralph Reed and invited me to come down
to Atlanta.
And the woman who,
who was my connection there and a moral
majority member,
I asked her,
I said,
well,
if John McCain gets the nomination,
will you vote for him?
And she said,
yeah.
So you know,
people that what the,
what the religious right needs to
understand is that there's religion and
there's politics and religion is about
saving your immortal soul and if you
mess with the devil you in danger it and
politics,
you make pacts with the devil all the
time.
It's about getting into office and
trying to practically changed some
things.
And one thing that I wanted to talk yes
to talk to you about that I just
remembered it.
The home studio so we can keep going.
Yeah,
you go ahead.
Go ahead.
Is this um,
why is the,
why is the left and now so called
liberalism?
Why are progressive totalitarians?
And the answer is that they,
it's,
it's a crypto.
Religious ideology.
It's modeled on Christianity in the
world is a fallen place so that he never
used that.
The world is an oppressive place.
It's injustice rules.
But there will be a redemption and we
are the redeemer's.
That's the danger we have to re and they
use it all the time.
We have to remake humanity so it fits
our model of the redemption.
That's why they're so,
so if only Bernie was in,
we have to outlaw.
We have to stamp out racist,
sexist,
homophobic people who we disagree with.
Milo,
we can let him speak.
That is what is the only difference
between that and an actual totalitarian
state is if they had the power,
they would execute my law.
It'd be in a gulag or he'd be dead.
Do you remember?
There was a line a couple of years ago
that oprah who and I basically like
Oprah and respect are open and I'd be
happy to run the show.
Of course when she was talking about the
older generation and some of their
backwards ways,
Vega and she said,
well,
we just,
they just have to die.
I remember thinking like,
even if what you're saying that yes,
there might be,
you know,
studies show that younger people are
generally more liberal on the social
issue,
not more liberal.
They'll,
right.
The older blacks are liberal.
That's why Oprah doesn't like them that
so well,
that sort of fits everything else that
you're saying,
but.
But my point being that when she said,
it sounds so nice to me because one day
if you just,
if you take that logic to its end,
guess what?
One day the young people are gonna want
all of you did when you're old because
it just will.
It'll just keep going.
Can't try to make sense out of it.
But it is,
it's the reverse.
It's the actually the reverse
shareholder.
Blacks
I know as racist,
as younger blacks,
racism is pervasive now.
I mean this is a very politically
incorrect to say,
but I think it's pretty obvious racist,
pervasive racism is pervasive in the
black community and especially among
younger people who've been to schools
and told that their all their problems
come from white racist.
Very bad.
You know,
the fifties were much better times in
this country.
So I think I only got a half answer then
before you said my head doesn't have a
lot of hope.
Something to that effect about Roger.
But what about you?
Well,
I'm,
I'm an optimist by genes.
I don't know.
Wow.
I am.
I just am.
I,
you know,
I phrased it in a book I wrote.
I,
when my head is in conflict with my
heart,
I followed my heart,
so I'm going to fight so I drop as long.
There's going to be a positive outcome.
But um,
you know,
there's that.
What was his name?
Skipio Africanness was a Roman general
who burned carthage.
And when he saw carthage going up in
smoke,
he wept because the classical view was
that,
oh,
it's all cyclical empires rise and fall,
societies rise and fall.
And this idea of progress is one of the
really bad ideas that the Jews gave to
us.
The idea,
what is the promise land,
although maybe Moses didn't beat it in a
way that left this meeting,
but that idea of a progress is the
problem.
Can't redeem the world,
can't be fixed.
Why can't the world be fixed?
Because the root source of all social
problems is us individuals.
So you can maybe,
you know,
it's,
it's very hard to take one individual
who's gone off the day band and bring
them back.
Yeah.
But you know,
modest.
It's,
you know,
and this is the oldest thing as the
voltaire 10 year old garden.
You can make the space around.
You may be a little bit more humane.
You can help an individual,
but you can't change the world.
Well,
on that note I sent,
we could do a lot more,
so we'll have to do this again.
Okay.
We'll see.
Maybe we'll do this.
How about we do this one year from now
and we'll see if I've incorporated
optimist.
I'm an optimist.
I can't.
No,
I'm old enough to know that,
that,
that will be a blessing.
You're 78 years old.
How do you look?
So good.
Your makeup,
that's all the makeup.
No,
I saw you when you walk in and come on.
What's the trick?
No,
no.
I have a great marriage.
Wonderful Wife.
Um,
I tried to balance the political with
you.
Real,
real life stuff.
My animals.
I have all these dogs I love.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know.
And it's also in the genes.
All right.
One year from now we will do it again.
And for more on David,
you can check out his new book,
big agenda of President Trump's plan to
save America and visit Horowitz,
freedom center.org.